battle mage has been released and as of
this video there are plenty of reviews
praising it or maybe even saying almost
Intel while the comment sections are
full of people fighting over numbers or
other nonsense however I'm excited for
the new arc in Intel's lineup of gpus
get it especially if they release a b380
sometime in 2025 but as for one final
sendoff and for the sake of our little
discussion today I wanted to give the
ark A380 one last look because while is
a bit too late for me to say this it
looks like this is finally a GPU that I
can sort of
[Music]
recommend I made two whole videos
reviewing this card and if youve seen
those older videos you would know that I
personally didn't think the A380 was
worth nearly anyone's time but if you
saw my recent $500 build you would have
heard me mention that time do change and
that specifically The Arc A380 is sort
of an anomaly how so well I will do my
best to not try and waste everyone's
time but let's talk about the three main
issues a lot of people had with Intel's
Arc cards and go through whether or not
things have been improved on or outright
fixed in the last couple of years let's
start with one that is near and dear to
my heart considering I never got to
fully investigate its details due to my
issues with resizable bar for some PC
gaming is very very expensive whether
the factors be where you live to what's
even available at the time one of my
biggest issues with Arc let alone the
A380 was that you need a new system to
really use the card at all or cards
considering its heavy Reliance on
resizable bar this hasn't changed but
what did change was the market besides
the arc A380 itself somehow becoming
cheaper so did everything else including
motherboards with the golden feature and
this also includes the used Market
beginning to populate with boards
holding this requirement for reasonable
prices my biggest gripe still is that
you need a resizable bar which
eliminates the idea of buying a cheap
old Del op duplex for 50ish bucks and
throwing this guy in there but as it
stands there really isn't anything like
this new that you can buy on the market
currently that being said if this video
does get like 100,000 views or whatever
for no reason I will attempt to do the
rebar driver mod that in theory would
make it Poss possible to use our cards
on older systems but uh anyways now it
is fair and reasonable for many people
to buy this card especially when you are
on a tighter budget when building an all
new system I show that this was very
possible in my $500 budget build that I
posted recently oh check it out if you
haven't already it's pretty
reasonable yeah yeah yeah we get it
budget bin but I only play older games
like directx9 titles and the art cards
don't even have native support for it so
uh yeah it was true that back then
playing directex 9 titles or even 10 or
11 was essentially a no-go due to the
API having to be emulated it literally
made no sense to many budget Gamers
considering you could just buy an old 20
or $40 GPU if you wanted to play your
Classics with ease cheaply this is my
biggest gripe with Intel's Arc cards
well it was before I show you all the
newer games that I tested all three of
them I took the liberty of itemizing all
the games I own off the noggin that I
enjoyed one way or the other varying in
release date direct X version Etc and
gave them all basic taste tests as to
whether or not they were running at
virtually Max settings while not
chugging or dropping frames and well
besides one game that I will go into in
a second everything ran fantastic every
title I played ran amazingly at Max
settings or near Max settings and titles
that were previously running terribly
are not running much to begin with run
at near Perfection now if I remember
correctly GTA 5 in particular had to be
lowered to 720p and it still sucked even
when I had to lower settings to medium
or low but now I can run at a 1080p with
high settings and Achieve 100 FPS quite
easily truly the GPU 180 or you could
say
380 and really became usable with with
these older games the only game out of
the 28 older titles that I tested that
didn't run was civilization 5 and this
feels more like an exception more than
the rules since it straight up won't
boot it might have something to do with
the 2K launcher that was embedded into
the game's startup having been ripped
out recently even though the game did
work on my main rig but this isn't a
huge deal breaker honestly especially
considering how well every game I have
played has run th far okay well that's
cool and I'll budget bin but I play new
newer games and the A380 isn't going to
run any of those since it it sucks well
it half sucks I imagine a majority of
AAA titles being released in 2025 won't
be able to run with this card and
certainly many games this year and even
the previous year will struggle a tad to
run as well I show that it could run
games like Red Dead Redemption 2 at Fair
settings with decent performance with
plenty of room to tweak to the liking of
the player and my reasonable $500 budget
build video as well as cyberpunk 2077
which ran splendidly under the same
notion that moving it preset down can
achieve higher frame rates I'm not a
rich YouTuber who can afford to pay for
every major title that releases
especially at Price tags like
$69.99 but I do have a couple of games
that appear to run reasonably that
released in the last year or two but
first let's start with Counter-Strike 2
yeah that game that came out in 2012
seriously Val please fix but I wanted to
start with this game because it runs
fairly nice in high settings which tells
me any newer major Esports that release
will run great on this card given how
low speec the games are to begin with
all things considered which is great to
see I was worried that the game would
struggle personally but then again I did
get deadlock to run on this GPU so yeah
I shouldn't be too surprised I suppose
Hitman 3 or technically Hitman world of
assassination is the next title I
checked but also this is basically a
game from 2016 or the engine is whatever
listen last old game I promise but I
figured it would be important for me to
mention this since the game is pretty
resource intensive and during my tests I
figured it would have some bloating
stutters but with a mix of medium and
high settings it was really stable like
I have no major complaints outside of
that I wish it ran better but for the
price of a tad over
$100 brand new
I mean it would be pretty stupid to
create some sort of issue out of it not
achieving a th000 FPS here so cool
what's next well this is where I feel
like I ran into what's more of another
exception but not the rule sort of
situation let me paint the picture I
begin to bench the game hell divers 2
seeing what runs decently at 1080P and
pretty much knew I wasn't going to go
anywhere above medium settings and
spoiler
found out the setting between low and
medium the steam deck preset was
actually the best upon fiddling with
sliders and whatnot cool this isn't too
bad and provides us with wiggle room
even the ability to lower our resolution
to get what we are looking for nice
however something terribly frightening
happened during my
testing and uh made the game unplayable
now I know what you're thinking Intel
messed up one way or the other possibly
yeah but I am also willing to bet this
could also just be a glitch in general
from the game it isn't the cleanest AAA
title made especially with its
history uh but still not fun to see or
rather not see no matter what settings I
changed it still happened by the way so
yeah a tad disappointing to see not see
it could be a case by case situation by
the way or the planet I was on but I
don't feel like playing this game for 10
hours to find a definitive answer since
I have one last major title to share
with all of you get ready to be shocked
as much as I was because I'm about to
show you stalker 2 running with the ark
A380 which the official minimum
requirements call for an ark
a750 just to be able to play at 1080p
low with an FPS Target of 30 now I won't
show any complex Frame data not because
I wasn't able to collect it but because
well I'm not quite sure how to Benchmark
this game currently but because more
importantly well you know what I just
dig right in and you will get to see
what I mean here we have the game at
1080p low it appears that we aren't
quite reaching that 30fps goal we're
about 12 FPS under it and no amount of
looking up at the sky will save us
unplayable just outright so we could
lower our resolution to 1,600 900 but we
will just go straight to 720p because it
won't change much no hope I suppose well
let's change our resolution back to
1080p real quick and try something a bit
different let's enable FSR 3 frame
generation and see if that helps in any
way H maybe a tad like a one frame
increase okay let's enable our upscaler
x s and put it on balanced at 50
and wao
would you look at that we are getting
over 40 FPS no issue now and even
kissing 50 that's huge we barely have to
crank the up Skiller to achieve this too
even when setting the up Skiller to
ultra quality plus we still sit around
40 here and while I don't see too much
of a quality increase this isn't half
bad in the slightest besides the screen
tearing that I'm experiencing this
really changes the game metaphorically
for the card I played around with
settings more more and found out that
you can achieve around 60 FPS while
staying at Ultra quality Plus at 720p
and it made me very happy to see this
around a year ago I wouldn't believe
this would have been possible with Intel
considering how they seemingly couldn't
get their drivers under control and work
correctly with some of the latest or
recent releases but now I'm going to be
honest and tell you that I'm speechless
originally I was going to wrap up this
video explaining that yes you could
taste some new titles for bit with this
card and that ultimately most people who
are buying a GPU like the arc A380 are
only doing it because they want a new
card that is fairly cheap has a warranty
and so they can get into a higher level
of gaming now while not paying $3 or
$400 on a big GPU at the cost of not
being able to play half of them today
but now I'm wondering after testing all
these games stalker 2 included how much
more I could actually run like could I
get Allen wake to run surely not the new
Indiana Jones game won't run for sure
but what about everything else releasing
in the next year I'm even kind of
contemplating doing that bios mod here
after I finish this video with the $100
hyper budget gaming PC in general just
to see if it's easy or maybe if it works
or not because if it does then maybe
this is actually one of the best budget
cards on the $100 is price point if not
technically the only new
one but even if you don't like the the
idea of upscaling using frame generation
Tech I still believe this is a great
budget card for people who don't want to
play the latest AAA games you certainly
won't have to worry about any indie game
struggling with it feel like that was
sort of the point of the A380 gaming
just well enough besides all of the
stuff that has already been said about
video encoding and whatnot with our
cards I can see someone pushing this
thing to its limits and getting a lot
done with it although in a way it is a
little too late for me to tell if this
card is finally worth buying at the time
of writing you can buy an RK 380 on New
Egg Amazon eBay even new at the price
point of roughly $110 before taxes this
is great but since battle mage launched
earlier this month I doubt they will
continue to stock slash make the A380
for much longer if not right now I do
think they will be coming out with a
b380 which when they do you know I'm
going to review ASAP but I don't think
they will be as cheap as the a380s are
currently they will likely be under 200
bucks which is still great and as long
as they have 8 GB of vram and some RT
cores or whatever then cool keep the
card small and have a few ITX options
like the ASRock Challenger here and you
got yourself a competitive small system
GPU that can actually shake up the
market given how well the b580 and b570
has performed thus far I have high hopes
for Intel even if they are a bit slow
nowadays or try to innovate in other
places people don't think much about but
in the end I feel like they redeemed
themselves in my eyes by making this
$110 paper weight into a relatively
decent budget entry level
GPU I am glad I could end this Trilogy
on a high note I was afraid Intel would
never get the proper drivers for it to
work and that it would be nothing but a
lesson in history for people looking at
AR cards in its story I just can't wait
to start the next one when the b380
eventually comes out whenever that is
but uh I hope that you will stay tuned
when that video does come out so
subscribe if you want to see that if you
like this video like it comment what you
think I would love to see what you guys
think or if you're interested in the new
ark battle mage series cards seriously
I'm I'm pretty excited myself also
follow me on Blue Sky I promise I will
be active there and honestly I'm kind of
done with Twitter as usual like favorite
subscribe share five star yada yada yada
and oh as always thanks for watching